is to keep the rate of increase of the
spread of the disease to a level that we
can manage it in our hospital system we
have 53,000 hospital beds available
right now the curve suggests we could
need a hundred and ten thousand hospital
beds and that is an obvious problem and
that's what we're dealing with
you have the nation's role in this
situation you will also have the state's
role this is what they call an emergency
management situation and there are rules
for emergency management who does what
basically this state governments local
governments manage an emergency unless
the emergency overwhelms the capacity of
the local government and then the higher
level of government takes over that
happens even on a state level a city
will be in charge a county will be in
charge unless it overwhelms their
capacity and then the state comes in and
takes over the federal government has
made a decision to leave the states in
charge of deciding quarantine procedures
whether to open whether to close that's
why you see New York taking certain
actions Illinois taking certain actions
different states taking certain actions
because the federal government thus far
has said different situations in
different states let the state's decide
dependent upon the number of cases they
have and I think that has been right to
date that could change but it's been
right to date however the federal
government should nationalize
medical-supply acquisition the states
simply cannot manage it this state
cannot manage it states all of course
the country can't manage it certainly
the states that are dealing with the
highest caseload can't handle it but
you're hearing it all of course the
country from states they just can't deal
with finding the medical supplies that
they need and that's why I believe the
federal government should take over that
function
of contracting and acquiring all the
medical supplies that we need currently
when states are doing it we are
competing against other states in some
ways we're savaging other states I'm
trying to buy masks I'm competing with
California and Illinois and Florida and
that's not the way it should be frankly
price gouging is a tremendous problem
and it's only getting worse
there are masks that we were paying
eighty five cents for we're now paying
seven dollars
why because I'm competing against every
other state and in some cases against
other countries around the world
ventilators which are the most precious
piece of equipment for this situation
they range in price from sixteen
thousand dollars to forty thousand
dollars each and New York state needs 30
thousand ventilators this is just an
impossible situation to manage if we
don't get the equipment we can lose
lives that we could have otherwise saved
if we had the right equipment
the federal government has two options
to handle this voluntary partnership
with companies where the federal
government says the companies I would
appreciate it if you would work with us
and do this and the president has done
that and he seems to have gotten a good
response on a voluntary basis the other
way is what's called the defense
production act where the federal
government has the legal authority to
say to companies you must produce this
now it is invoking a federal law it is
mandating that private companies do
something but I think it is appropriate
if I had the power I would do it in New
York State because the situation is that
critical I think the federal government
should order factories to manufacture
mass
Jones ventilators the essential medical
equipment that's going to make the
difference between life and death it's
not hard to make a mask or PPE equipment
or a gown but you need companies to do
it we have apparel companies that can
make clothing well then you can make a
surgical gown and you can make a mask
but they have to be ordered to do it if
the federal government does it then they
can do it in a very orderly way they can
decide how many they need they can
designate how many each factory should
produce and then they could distribute
those goods by need rather than having
these states all compete against each
other it would also be less expensive
because it would avoid the price gouging
that is now happening in this
marketplace
I can tell what's happening our contract
with the company for 1,000 masks they'll
call back
20 minutes later and say the price just
went up because they had a better offer
and I understand that other states who
are desperate for these Goods literally
offer more money than we were paying and
it's just a a race that's raising prices
higher and higher we even have hospitals
competing against other hospitals if the
federal government came in used the
defense production act you could resolve
all of that immediately also we need the
product now we have cries from hospitals
around the state
I've spoken to other governors around
the country they have the same situation
they need these materials now and only
the federal government can make that
happen so I believe the federal
government should immediately utilize
the defense production act implemented
immediately let's get those medical
supplies running and let's get them
moving as quickly as possible in terms
of federal government funding they
should prioritize
the funding individuals need money
you're laid off you're going paycheck to
paycheck we took care of the rent issue
here in New York the mortgage payment
but you have to buy food you have to buy
essentials and if you haven't worked and
you're laid off you're in trouble so I
think the federal government is exactly
right the president has talked about
this get funding to the into the pockets
of families that need it to live second
money to governments I'm spending money
right now that we don't have
I'm not going to deprive people of
medical services but the economy has
stopped people are not paying their
taxes if you're not paying your taxes
that's a state source of revenue so
funding from the federal government is
essential for me and third the corporate
subsidies that the president is talking
about I think is also right but the
corporate funding should not be a gift
to corporations at the taxpayers expense
let's learn from what happened in 2008 I
was Attorney General at that time in the
state of New York where we bailed out
corporations they bought back stock they
paid they paid their corporate
executives handsomely they benefited
from taxpayer money and the taxpayers
wound up getting none of the profits the
citizens should benefit from the
corporate success if the government
takes equity if the government charges
an interest rate but this time if the
taxpayers are going to bail out these
big corporations make sure the taxpayers
share in the success of these
corporations let's do it right this time
also the federal funding they're working
on another coronavirus bill
I was in Washington for eight years this
should not be the usual sausage-making
of pork barrel right when you do a piece
of legislation in Washington most
legislators it becomes the expression
sausage-making it becomes pork barrel it
goes through the political process and
the political process says everybody
should get some money which dilutes the
funding gives it to communities and
governments that don't really need the
funding and doesn't even address the
need it's one of the reasons why people
are so suspect of government spending
right because it winds up pork barrel
every senator is going to say I want
money from my state every Congress
person says I want money for my local
district I want to be able to go home
with a little package that I can hand to
my local government that's not what this
is about
in this case this is about addressing a
need and getting funding precious
funding the people in places that need
it and the rule here should be money
follows the need it's that simple what
place is needed self-serving but New
York State has 15 times more cases than
any other state right now fund the
state's fund the places that need it
follow the number of cases and use need
as the basis for funding it's common
sense it will be respected by the people
of this nation and the alternative to
politicize this funding process is
intolerable to my congressional
delegation I say look New York received
no funding from the first coronavirus
bill even though New York has the
greatest need and that was a technical
mistake in the way they wrote the bill
political custom is one politician
politician or elected officials should
not pressure people of their own party
my congressional delegation is largely
Democrat so political custom would be
well don't pressure another democratic
elected official I say that is baloney I
represent all the citizens of the state
of New York that is my job it's a very
simple job I have I fight for New
Yorkers period Democrats Republicans
period and this is no time to play
politics and we need our congressional
delegation to stand up and to fight for
New York also on the federal role I'm
requesting today from the federal
government that the Army Corps
immediately proceeded to erect temporary
hospitals I went out yesterday I
surveyed the sites there are several
good options that give us regional
coverage a an Army Corps temporary
hospital at Stony Brook which is on Long
Island Westbury which is on Long Island
Westchester where we have that terrible
cluster which is thank goodness reducing
and the Javits Center which is a very
large convention center in Manhattan in
New York and New York City is obviously
where we have the highest number of
cases the I met with the Army Corps
they've reviewed these sites I approve
it I approve it on behalf of the state
of New York and now we just have to get
it done and get it done quickly these
temporary hospitals are helpful but they
don't bring supplies and they don't
bring staff and that compounds our
problem of not having enough medical
supplies and frankly compounds our
staff because we are trying to increase
the capacity in our existing hospitals
the the sites that we picked
allow for
endure assembly of these facilities so
they won't be out of doors
they'll be indoors some places we may
need to do them outdoors but these
campuses also have dormitories where the
healthcare staff can stay they're very
large there's a space and again I have
made all necessary approvals so from my
point of view construction can start
tomorrow
these are pictures of the places where
we would assemble them in Stony Brook
Old Westbury Westchester County Center
in Westchester all indoor locations all
open already accessible Jacob Javits
Center we just expanded it it's one of
the largest convention centers in the
country it's open it is ready to go
there is no red tape on the side of New
York we're also asking FEMA to come in
Federal Emergency Management Agency to
come in and erect for federal hospitals
at the Javits Center the federal
hospital by FEMA is different than the
Army Corps of engineer temporary
facility the FEMA hospitals come with
staff and with supplies they're in 250
bed configurations we're asking for four
of those 250 bed configurations to be
assembled in the Javits Center the
Javits Center can easily manage them
it's in the heart of Manhattan they're
fully equipped they're fully staffed
again we are ready to go as soon as the
federal government is ready to go that
will then give us regional coverage in
downstate New York which is our most
heavily impacted area the President
signed the FEMA emergency declaration
which allows FEMA to go to work by that
emergency declaration funding for these
services is split 75% by the federal
government 25% by the state
government the federal government can
waive the state's share as they call it
waive the 25 percent from the state
I'm also requesting that the president
waved the 25 percent
I just cannot pay the 25 percent we
literally don't have the funding to do
it and by the way I don't believe any
state will be in a position to waive the
25 percent so I don't just say that on
my behalf I say that on behalf of all
the governor's I'm the vice chairman of
the National Governors Association I've
been speaking with governors all across
the nation no state has the financial
capacity to participate in my opinion
but I know for sure New York doesn't
because we are the heavy heaviest hit
state right now I'm asking the president
to do what I did here in the state of
New York cut the red tape cut the
bureaucracy just cut to the chase get
the army of Corvette engineers moving to
get FEMA moving let's get those
buildings up let's have them in place
before that trajectory hits its apex
time matters minutes count and this is
literally a matter of life and death we
get these facilities up we get the
supplies we will save lives if we don't
we will lose lives I don't mean to be
overly dramatic but I want to be honest
and that is the simple fact of this
matter we're also implementing the trial
drug we have secured 70,000 hydro
chloric 110 thousand 0 max from the
federal government I want to thank the
FDA for moving very expeditiously to get
us this supply the president ordered the
FDA to move and the FDA moved we're
going to get this supply and the trial
will start this Tuesday the president is
optimistic about this
about these drugs and we are all
optimistic that it could work I've
spoken with a number of health officials
and there is a good basis to believe
that they could work some health
officials point to Africa which has a
very low infection rate and there's a
theory that because they're taking this
anti-malarial drug in Africa it may
actually be one of the reasons why the
infection rate is low in Africa we don't
know but let's find out and let's find
out quickly
and I agree with the President on that
and we're going to start and we're going
to start Tuesday I also think the FDA
should start approving cereal logical
testing for corona virus antibodies and
they should do it as soon as possible
what this does is it tests the blood to
see if you have antibodies that were
created to fight the corona virus
remember all the health officials say
the corona virus was here before we
started to test many more people have
had the corona virus than we think most
people have resolved the corona virus
who have had it how do you know that you
can test and find the antibody that the
body created to fight the virus if you
have that antibody it means you had the
virus and you resolved it why do you
want to know that because I want to know
who had it who has the antibody which
means they most probably will not get it
again and that can help us get our
medical staff back to work faster so
it's a different level of testing but I
think the FDA should move as
expeditiously as they have before on
this type of testing find out who had it
who has the antibodies and that will
help us especially on
medical staff shortages also on the
state role what am I supposed to do
we're not just looking to the federal
government I understand that we are
responsible here in the state of New
York and we're doing everything we can
on hyperspeed we have to expand the
existing hospital capacity this gets
back to the 53,000 current beds when we
may need a hundred and ten thousand beds
we have said to the hospital
administrators we have a goal of you
increasing your capacity in each
Hospital by 100 percent yes an ambitious
goal yes very difficult yes it may be
impossible in some places but remember a
hospital is highly regulated space is
regulated the number of beds in a room
is highly regulated we're waiving all
those regulations and saying just from a
physical capacity point of view see if
you can increase your capacity 100
percent where we get 100% we have 53
thousand beds we have to get to 110
thousand beds everybody increases by a
hundred percent we meet the goal simple
a little too simple but we understand
many hospitals won't be able to do it
however at a minimum hospitals must give
us a plan to increase capacity by at
least 50 percent so we would be at about
75,000 minimum against the 110 need we
would still have to find additional beds
I understand that and you see what we're
doing with the federal government
there's an opportunity there but every
Hospital goal of 100 percent increase in
capacity mandate of 50 percent increase
in capacity we also have an intensive
care unit bed issue where we have to
increase the number of intensive care
units that is limited by the number of
ventilators what makes an Icee
you bet and I see you bet in this case
it's that the ICU bed has a ventilator
and that's where we get back to needing
the ventilators desperately so we have
those ICU beds we're putting out the
Department of Health emergency order to
hospitals that says we're not just
asking you to do this it wouldn't just
be a nice thing I'm not just asking you
as governor as a civic obligation this
is a law that the hospitals must come up
with a plan to increase capacity a
minimum of 50 goal of 100% we're also
cancelling all elective non-critical
surgery for hospitals as of Wednesday
elective non-critical if it's a critical
surgery fine if it's not critical
then postponing that alone should get us
25 to 35% more beds and again that is a
mandate that is going into effect for
the hospitals I understand the hospitals
are not happy about it I've heard that
the elective surgery is a big source of
revenue for the hospitals I understand
that but this is not about money this is
about public health and we're putting
that mandate in place starting today
we're also creating additional beds in
places where we can we're taking over
existing residential facilities hotels
nursing homes and repurposing existing
facilities for example this is the
Brooklyn Center for rehabilitation and
Healthcare 600 beds that we're going to
take over and it will serve as a
temporary hospital and we're doing this
in facilities all across the state two
different facts I want to make sure
we're clear just so there's no confusion
in fact one
young people can get the coronavirus
they are wrong when they say they can't
get it they can get it 18 to 49 year
olds represent 53 percent of the total
cases in New York this is not China this
is not South Korea on the theory that
well I'm an American youth and therefore
I'm have a superior immune system than
China South Korea know that theory is
not correct in New York 53 percent of
the cases 18 to 49 years old second fact
older people and those with compromised
immune system underlying illnesses can
die from the corona virus you're right
the 18 to 49 year old is probably not
lethal
but you can get it and you can get sick
and it's a nasty illness and then you
can transfer to someone else that's the
case for young people older people
obviously if you're a vulnerable person
it can be lethal both facts are true and
both facts have to be understood young
people can get it you will get sick you
probably won't die but you can transfer
it to someone who may very well die and
you can transfer even inadvertently
without knowing you're doing it you can
touch a surface walk away
a day later someone consider this table
and put their hand in the same place and
contract the virus I was in New York
City yesterday it was a pretty day there
is a density level in New York City that
is wholly inappropriate you would think
there was nothing going on in parts of
New York City you would think it was
just a bright sunny Saturday I don't
know what I'm
saying that people don't get I'm
normally accused of being overly blunt
and direct and I take that it's true I
don't know what they're not
understanding this is not life as usual
none of this is life as usual and this
kind of density we talk about social
distancing I was in these parks if you
would not you would not know that
anything was going on this is just a
mistake
it's a mistake it's insensitive it's
arrogant
it's self-destructive it's disrespectful
to other people and it has to stop and
it has to stop now this is not a joke
and I am not kidding we spoke with the
mayor of the city of New York and the
Speaker of the City Council Cory Johnson
I told both of them that this is a
problem in New York City it's especially
a problem in New York City Parks New
York City must develop an immediate plan
to correct this situation I want a plan
that we can review in 24 hours so that
we can approve it there are many options
you have much less traffic in New York
City because non-essential workers
aren't going to work get creative
open streets to reduce the density you
want to go for a walk god bless you you
won't go for a run god bless you but
let's open streets so it's open space
that's where people should be in open
space areas not in dense locations there
is no group activity in parks that is
not the point we spoke about it the
other day all sorts of kids playing
basketball yesterday I play basketball
there is no concept of social distancing
while playing basketball it doesn't
exist you
stay six feet away from a person playing
basketball you can but then you're a
lousy basketball player and you're gonna
lose you just cannot do that we also
have bigger parks in New York City we
open shirley chisholm Park in Brooklyn
400 acres Van Cortlandt Park there are
big parks there are big spaces that's
where you want to be but we need a plan
from New York City
I want it in 24 hours because this is a
significant problem that has to be
corrected in terms of numbers I said
yesterday New York is testing more
people than any state in the country and
per capita more than any country on the
globe that is a positive accomplishment
pardon the pun because we want we want
testing we want more testing we ramped
up very quickly we're doing it better
than anyone else and that is a good
thing because when you identify a
positive then you can isolate that
person and that's exactly what we're
trying to do when you increase the
number of tests you're going to increase
the number of people who test positive
and the numbers show exactly that we
have now tested 61 thousand people newly
tested 15,000 people so these numbers
just are exponential to what is being
done anywhere else in the country and
that's why you're going to see much
higher numbers than anywhere else
total number of new cases 15,000 I'm
sorry total number of cases 15,000 total
number of new cases 4,800 new cases you
see the state more and more counties
were just down to a handful of counties
now where we don't have existing cases
as I said that is going to be 100%
covered it's just a matter of time on
the hospitalization rate which is a
number that I watch very close
it's 1900 cases out of 15,000 13% 13% is
actually lower than it has been
we've been running at 15% 16% as high as
20%
this is 13% this is the key indicator
because this is saying how many people
are going to come in to your health care
system as the number goes up so this is
a is is not bad news across the country
you see New York now has 15,000 cases
Washington state 1600 California 1500 so
we have roughly 15 times the number of
cases now do we really have 15 times the
number of cases you don't know we're
testing much more than anyone else so
that is a major factor in this but I
have no doubt that we have more cases we
have more density we have more people
from other countries who come to New
York than many other states so I have no
reason to believe that we don't have
more I don't believe we have 15 times
more I believe that's also a factor that
we test more than anyone else
114 new deaths total number of deaths
374 and that is a sobering sad and
really distressing fact that should give
everyone pause because that's what this
is all about is saving lives and we've
lost 374 New Yorkers keeping it all in
perspective Johns Hopkins has followed
this from day one three hundred and
eleven thousand cases 13,000 deaths
statewide deaths to the extent we can
research the cause of death and the
demographic
of death what we're seeing roughly 70%
of those who passed away were seventy
years old or older and the majority had
underlying health conditions okay so it
is what we said it was approximately 80%
of the deaths of those under 70 years
old had an underlying health condition
so young people can get it young people
will get sick young people can transfer
mortality lethality older compromised
immune system underlying illness that's
what we're saying but even within that
population the capacity of our health
care system can save those lives it
doesn't mean just because you're 80 and
you have a compromised immune system or
you have an underlying health condition
and you get coronavirus you must pass
away that's going to depend on how good
our healthcare system is but in terms of
overall perspective I'm afraid for
myself I'm afraid for my sister I'm
afraid for my child
older underlying illness be very very
very careful this gets back to Matilda's
law this goes back to my mother that's
my fear this gets back to nursing home
senior care facilities etc
personal advice this is not factual I
try to present facts I've tried to
present everything I know I try to
present unbiased facts I try to present
numbers people need information when do
you get anxious when you get fearful
when you don't get the information or
you doubt the information or you think
people don't know what they're talking
about or you think you're getting lied
to so I present facts this is personal
advice
this is non factual so it's all
gratuitous you can take it you can throw
it in the pail but we have to think this
situation through don't be reactive at
this point to this situation yes you are
out of control in many ways you're out
of control to this virus you're out of
work
situations are changing they're not in
your control you don't even know how
long this is going to go on it's a very
frightening feeling that is true but you
can also take back some control start to
anticipate and plan what's going to go
on plan for the negatives and plan for
the positives there are going to be
negatives and they're all going to be
positive they're real economic
consequences how do you handle the
economic consequences you're not alone
it's everyone in the United States
that's why you see this federal
government acting quickly to get funding
into the pockets of families who need it
but think through what the economics
mean think through the social issues and
the social impact of this think through
the emotional issues of this you know it
would be unnatural if you didn't have a
flood of emotions going on it would be
unnatural either you wouldn't understand
what was happening or you wouldn't
appreciate it but if you know the facts
and you understand what's
you have to have a flood of individual
emotions positive and negative and
anticipate it you know stay home stay
home stay home whether you stay home
remember the old expression cabin fever
right you stay home alone you don't want
to be isolated emotionally you can be
isolated physically you don't want to be
isolated emotionally you want to keep
those emotional connections you want to
talk to people you want to write letters
you want to have emotional connectivity
that is very important if you're not
alone and you're in the house with the
family and the kids and everybody's
together that's a different set of
emotional complexities you know being in
that enclosed environment normally the
kids are out everybody's going to work
and you you're only together a short
period of time of day now you're all in
the same place for 24 hours you know I
remember when the kids were young what
it was like I was pure joy but I
remember what it was like to be with
them for multiple hours you know it's
complicated I live alone I'm even
getting annoyed with the dog you know
being in one place so think that through
because that is real and it's going to
go on for a period of time this is not a
short-term situation this is not a long
weekend this is not a week the timeline
nobody can tell you it depends on how we
handle it but 40% up to 80% of the
population will wind up getting this
virus all we're trying to do is slow the
spread but it will spread it is that
contagious again that's nothing to panic
over you saw the numbers unless you're
older with an underlying
illness etc it's something that you're
going to resolve but it's gonna work its
way through society will manage that
capacity rate but it is going to be four
months six months nine months you look
at China once they really change the
trajectory which we have not done yet
eight months we're in that range nobody
has a crystal ball
nobody can tell you well I want to know
I want to know I need to know nobody can
tell you I've spoken to more people on
this issue than 99% of the people in
this country no one can tell you not
from the superb doctor foul Qi to the
World Health Organization to the
National Institute of Health but it is
in that range so start the plan
accordingly it's going to be hard there
is no doubt I'm not minimizing it and I
don't think you should either
but at the same time it is going to be
okay we don't want to overreact either
right the grocery stores are gonna
function is going to be food the
transportation systems are going to
function the pharmacies are going to be
open all essential services will be
maintained there's not going to be chaos
there's not going to be Anarchy order
and function will be maintained life is
going to go on different but life is
going to go on so there is no reason to
be going to grocery stores and hoarding
food you see all this overreaction on
the TV every day which then makes you
think well maybe I'm I'm missing it
maybe I should run to the store and buy
toilet paper no life is going to go on
the toilet paper is going to be there
tomorrow so a deep breath on all of that
but I do believe that whatever this is
four months six months nine
months we are going to be the better for
it you know they talk about the greatest
generation the generation that survived
World War two dealing with hardship
actually makes you stronger life on the
individual level on the collective level
on the social level life is not about
avoiding challenges challenges are going
to come your way life is going to knock
you on your rear end at one point
something will happen and then life
becomes about overcoming those
challenges that's what life is about and
that's what this country is about
America is America because we overcome
adversity and challenges that's how we
were born that's what we've done all our
life we overcome challenges and this is
a period of challenge for this
generation and that's what has always
made America great and that's what's
going to make this generation great I
believe that to the bottom of my soul
we're going to overcome this and America
will be the greater for it and my hope
is that New York is going to lead the
way forward and together we will
questions on New York City reducing its
density is it within your powers to do
those sorts of things and and you're
talking about closing streets to traffic
to increase pedestrian traffic can you
explain the logic of what exactly that
would look like in New York City I could
make those decisions in New York City in
truth Jesse I only look first of all I'm
in New York City born and bred
if you can't tell so I know New York
City from every kind of dimension I
don't know the situation with the parks
well enough and I don't know the
situation on
opening streets closing streets well
enough and frankly I think the local
officials are in a better position to
make those decisions they see this issue
also it's not that they don't see the
issue they see the issue they see the
problem I want them to come up with a
plan I think they're in a better
position to do it I want to know what it
is and I want to approve it because this
is a serious problem that density has to
be reduced and it has to be reduced fast
and that's why I'm asking for a plan
from them in 24 hours but I think
they're in a better position to do it
closing parks and playgrounds and things
like that I want to see what they say
they know they know the problem they see
it I mean it's all over the place it's
not that you know you need a microscope
to find this it is all over the city now
maybe it was a nice day yesterday or
whatever but people who it's it was all
over the place
which I said that the main problem is
the equipment it's the gowns
[Music]
it's the masks it's the PPE equipment
and we sent a million masks to New York
City yesterday we have a million masks
here so we can supply hospitals but
we're talking about a very short period
of time within scrambling to buy all
these masks I have companies that are
manufacturing masks for us
we're buying sewing machines to make
masks but this is not the way it should
be done let the federal government they
have a law called the defense production
act which is precisely for this I get
the president saying he wanted to work
voluntarily with private companies and
asked them to help and I get the
president saying the private companies
were great and they came forward and
they said we want to help I get that I
say forget the voluntary partnership
order the companies to produce it let
the federal government do it so that the
private company doesn't wind up
marketing with all these states that are
competing think about it we paid 85
cents for a mask we're now paying seven
dollars for the same mask why because
California will pay six and Illinois
will pay six fifty and Florida will pay
six seventy five I'm just making up
those numbers but that's not the way it
should be let the federal government
take the function of Medical Supply
production and distribution just take it
right when it came to testing I said the
exact opposite I said to the President
on testing when everything was going
through the FDA and everything was going
through the CDC and it was slow I said
to the vice president D centralize it
give that function to me the state
I have 200 laboratories that i regulate
give it to me
I'll turn on 200 laboratories rather
than going through a bottleneck in the
federal government everything has to go
through the FDA and CDC so I said in
that in that situation
give me the task I'll get it done faster
so it's not like I'm trying to say the
federal government should do something
to take a burden off me I've accepted
the burden of testing from the federal
government and by the way our numbers
were through the roof this task they are
in a better position to do than I am
order the production of masks and gowns
and ventilators give them a deadline
don't get into this mad bidding war they
know how to distribute it because you
look at where the cases are and
distribute it by the need of the cases
from Washington let them take that this
is the the president can do this frankly
it's the president's style to say cut to
the chase this has to be done and I'm
mandating it and he should do that here
we are we I'm not willing to give up the
testing because the testing is one of
the ways we slow the spread there's only
two ways to slowly spread density
reduction which we're all over and we
can't do anything more than that we're
already at zero on non-essential workers
the second way is testing find the
positive isolate the positive so I'm not
willing to stop testing because because
our number one job is slow the
trajectory of the increase because I
can't handle it in the hospital system
but if the disease is becoming endemic
what's the point of testing I guess
there is a point of inflection you're
right where you could hit a point where
the disease is so widespread it's not
worth the testing we're not there yet
Jessie because we're still trying to
stop the apex right we have to bring
down that curve even if we're successful
on this health order where we get the
hospitals to go to 50% additional
capacity I'm still at only 75,000 beds
when we need 110 I'm still only at
13,000 ICU beds when I need 37,000 ICU
beds I'm still at only 6000 ventilators
when I need 30,000 ventilators so we
have to do everything we can to keep
that curve down and testing is essential
to that
that's what I want to see from New York
City I want New York City I want the
mayor of the City Council Speaker Cory
Johnson
let them come up with a plan get it to
me within 24 hours I want to approve it
but I'm open to anything but it has to
be done quickly and it's gonna have to
be dramatic action excuse me one second
because it's not I I can't say anything
more than I've said right how many times
can you say you're being reckless and
selfish and you know brings out the best
that brings out the worst we all talked
about being a community we're a
community what does a community mean
we're interconnected we're
interdependent I rely on you you rely on
me that's community that's us at our
best the community of New York I need to
be able to rely on you and that means
you have to be smart and responsible in
your actions
and you have to be able to rely on me
and then means I have to be smart and
responsible in my actions and that's the
social contract between us I have a
right to expect that from you especially
in dire circumstances and we're not
there and we should be there and I'm
gonna keep saying it but we're also
going to be doing it and I want the plan
from New York City to make that a
reality sorry I'm sorry
we are discussing we have done increased
absentee ballots for elections I think
is a good it's a good idea anyway we
should have done that a long time ago
it's especially a good idea when you
don't want a lot of people going to a
polling place
Melissa was handling that issue article
2 section 2 of the Constitution says
that there are only two ways that you
can vote absentee one is if you're sick
and the other is if you're unable to go
to the poll over time the legislature
has legislated what it means unable to
go to the poll as being out of County
and so what we're looking at is if our
executive authority will allow us to
overcome that or if we have to talk to
the legislature about changing the law
to allow for it exactly that's what
we're reviewing right now
know we've look we've done everything we
can
they are the vulnerable area right
because they're a congregation of the
vulnerable population we said no
visitors which is a really dramatic and
sad action right you're in a nursing
home you're alone you look forward to
family visiting and then we say no
family visitors we're encouraging and
working with the nursing homes for
telecommunications and Skype and
FaceTime and all that but nothing new
yes we have those regulations that
before the staff comes in they have to
be tested
got two separate tracks it's good
question two separate tracks one state
action assume no one else does anything
but you write and I operate on that
track assume the federal government
doesn't do anything and it's just New
York State in New York State alone and
we're going down that track and I'm
doing everything possible on every level
to do just that
and that's increasing the hospital
capacity minimum fifty percent goal of a
hundred percent they have to come up
with a staffing plan to do that that's
finding the medical supplies for them
I'm not stopping on the medical supplies
we are manufacturing masks I'm talking
to uniform manufacturers to get them
sewing machines to convert I have
apparel companies that manufacture in
China to stop making dresses to start
making gowns I mean we're doing every
kind of thing we can do
child care facilities for healthcare
workers special protections for
healthcare workers assume the federal
government does nothing and we have that
plan in place at the same time I am
saying to the federal government you
need to do what you need to do there is
a federal role here and this emergency
management protocol well we support the
states yeah you support the states if
the states can do it
that's what the emergency management
protocol is I do this as a governor
there's a flood in Erie County okay
you're a county you're in charge call me
if you need something yeah I get that
but if I know the flood can't be handled
by Erie County then I come in and I'm
the governor and I come in and I say the
county executive we're here I'm the
governor I'm gonna bring state resources
I'm saying to the federal government
that I'm saying to the president you
should take over the medical supply
function invoke fully the federal
defense production Act
order manufacturing companies to
manufacture it every state is saying
every city is saying they're running out
of medical supplies do that B get FEMA
get the Army Corps of Engineers you have
the sites tell them to come up here
tomorrow and start building those
emergency hospitals C pass the funding
don't let the Congress make a pork
barrel don't let them make it political
patronage where everybody brings home 50
cents but you actually don't fund the
places that need it and the people that
need it
help the corporations but don't help the
corporations like we did in 2008 where
the senior executives get tens of
millions of dollars in bonuses and now
the taxpayers are supposed to fund that
Corporation to bail them out and then
the corporation two years from now is
making record profits and the normal
economy hasn't rebounded and the
taxpayer who subsidized the corporation
is still troubling to pay their mortgage
we did that in 2008 you want to give a
corporation money say okay here are the
rules you can't buy back stock
I want the bonuses to CEOs back I want a
equity stake in the company
I want interest in the company interest
rate on the loan but something that gets
the profit back to the citizen you know
we're tired of making these big
corporations rich at taxpayers expense
make sure we make sure the corporation's
live up to their civic responsibility
and you have total responsibility if
you're going to give them taxpayers max
payer money then you get to write the
rules you know from the president's
point of view this is back to his old
job right somebody walks in and says I
want an investment in my company okay
I'll give you an investment in your
company but here are the rules
before I give you the investment in that
company I need the federal government to
do that the emergency supplies the
funding to the places that need it
I need my congressional delegation to
actually represent the state of New York
and deliver we need FEMA here we need
Army Corps of Engineers here we need
those functions working as quickly as
possible and then we need federal
assistance from the federal government
if none of that happens then we're on
our own we're New Yorkers we'll figure
it out what I'm sorry you cannot be
evicted for non-payment of rent one
other piece of good news you know we
talk about all these increasing cases
and you get the virus most people the
virus resolves a good friend of mine
great public official ricotta n-- a head
of the Port Authority he had the corona
virus never hospitalized he was home for
two weeks he is now tested negative for
the corona virus so he self resolved it
was about two weeks I don't even know
that he needed at all two weeks I'm a
little suspicious that maybe he resolved
in one week and then he just took
another week vacation but I don't want
to push the point I'm gonna go to work
thank you guys very much these stay what
oh we are overwhelmed in the website we
have 700 people working on the website
and telephones to handle the inflow of
insurance claims
it is crashing because we've never seen
this volume the IT consultants can't
even figure out how how to handle the
volume the volume is that high but we
have 700 people working on the website
and phones etc to process those claims I
know people are frustrated I get it but
we have never seen a volume like this in
any state agency ever
[Applause]
I'm having a very difficult time with
captain who's really getting on my
nerves
besides that chocolate